das nächste foto kommt von meinem besten
freund julian co was jetzt willkommen
war ein video sollte ich auf euch jetzt
gut ich weiß gar nicht warum ich immer
klatsche wenn ich irgendwas sagen auf
jeden fall habe ich mit leute was ganz
besonderes überlegt ich glaube so was
habe ich auf youtube auch noch nie
gesehen um das ganze durchführen zu
können
es geht gar nicht alleine deswegen mal
einen riesenapplaus für einen
mitbewohner
juli wird auch bestimmt leute ich glaube
die haben vielleicht länger kein video
mehr zusammen gemacht deswegen machen
wir das mal wieder was machen wir heute
leicht von instagram wider erwarten
genau als wären uns jeder rausgesucht
als erste ich hier und sie zeigen hat an
dem anderen an der modell der raten die
finger leckte foto hat das soll auf
jeden fall nicht oberflächlichen ball
kommen soll witzig sein und mal gucken
ob wir das ungefähr erraten können wir
haben auch eigentlich nur bilder von
irgendwelchen in vent und da
irgendwelche lustigen bilder genommen
deswegen ich hoffe ihr habt spaß das
noch um das gefällt und bei julia offe
schöne gibt auch noch ein paar tagen
konnte man zwar kommst du dir schon
fängt also wenn ich gewinne dann muss
auch wichtig als ersten kleinen jungs
natureworks look zunächst erster in
flößer selbst erstes ins weltall erstes
instagram bitten weil man wurde das
gefühl sich recht kann mir sagen ende
was ein richtiger steilen also ich würd
mal sagen das müsste so ungefähr also es
hat sich über 10.000 mein erstes ist das
gerne das könnte jetzt auch sogar noch
mehr haben oder es hat halt wirklich
weniger ich will das einfach nur sagen
das hat 11.000 sogar gleich richtig nee
wir zeigen uns gegenseitig einzelne er
daran hast du vielleicht kurz damit
stufe steht also zeigen uns die alt
gegenseitig und werde dann näher dran
liegt an dem
richtigen wert der hat gewonnen sagt
11.500 f das durchleiten 9700 leicht war
es nur so wenig konkretes zu hören
damit es fair ist sonst wird es da gar
keinen sinn machen wenn ich jetzt ein
foto von irgendwem nehmen würde deine
millionen likes of â so nehmen wir
einfach auch ein von mir okay das macht
ihr dann sind gekürt und zwar wie
vielleicht sagt dieses bild war das 10
15.000 live problem mehr als vielmehr
sein den leser nicht sagen das bild hat
16.000 1019 1632 ja hunde geht auf mich
als ragen der verlierer aus unserer
küche auf das nächste bild ist von einer
top influence darin auf deutschland
katja 67.000 gleich wieder komplett
instagram ich ja man also über eine
million und keine jugendliche haben wir
in deutschland zwar gefunden
die schlinge was auch nicht ins foto
hier und weiß dass der typ der die
bachelorette also das jetzt mit dieser
berg ist etwas menschliches bachelor hat
mit des zusammen wie viele leichte
vorteile
keine ahnung alter kann ich mir sagen
wie viel voll war der hat 300.000 300
auf die viele leichter diese
wahrscheinlich übermenschlich viele
alter oder kompletten
aber wenn ich schon so sagt dann will
ich sagen gerne 50.000 20.000 vielleicht
auch die zweite liga nicht
170000 sind 104 bereiten kratzen
natürlich dingen keine ahnung sowie noch
mehr wetzlar war ehrlich so hat sie
immer gesagt mein bestes gibt mir haben
sich mal wehren der händler weiter
woher soll ich den typen von der wester
recke da ich immer die nächste staaten
ja dann stadtduma
das nächste foto kommt von meinem besten
freund julian khol die schliche
ich würde sagen eiskalten 400.000
400.000 weil sie sagen mit 14.400 10.000
und 50.000 war er hat uns immer so viele
tausend ich wollte auch im bild und wie
den kunden dann machen wir ein bisschen
schwer wie viel hat ihn verliebt links
sänger mike singer 760 ausgleich zum 6 6
die 4 eigentlich müssten wir gar nicht
weiter machen weist jetzt drei mal für
mich geht machen wir noch ein wunder so
aus spaß vielleicht seinem kleinen
ehrentreffer
jetzt kommt einer der top influenza
deutschland wundervoll model wieviel
1648 1348 1223 man muss eigentlich mal
zwei bilder finden die vom niveau auf
einer stufe sind aber dass ich da mal so
dass vortrag zwischen fünf und zehn tage
muss jetzt dran sein muss sind 1000 1
6300 jetzt ihr neues ich dachte es war
easy kopfproblem geht weiter egal wir
haben auch mehr celik wir machen noch
ein video der heute das war es
eigentlich schon mit dem video ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen und die hat etwas
zu machen es war auf jeden fall witzig
wenn wir das noch machen sollen dann
schickt uns gerne vor dass zu und lassen
nach oben da steckt auch jetzt julis
video aufs ganze der videos einen
verlinkt jedoch schneller infekte
eingeblendet wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder vielleicht ganz gut morgen laden
video hoch aus meinem urlaub auf ibiza
ich saß auf jeden fall ziemlich lange
dran deswegen wäre cool wenn ich das
anschaut und mehr weil es nicht sagen
haut rein